et à la demande et fait cesser cette
tempête de neige sinon mon peuple mourra
[Musique]
anna ne suis pas un terroriste
iam non je ne suis pas un terroriste je
ne suis pas un terroriste
[Musique]
de nos jours peu importe vous êtes vous
êtes surveillés très probablement les
drones militaires ont fait des milliers
de morts innocents et peuvent attaquer à
tout moment et n'importe où comme ils
veulent à plus de 10 mètres d'altitude
vous ne vous rendrez même que vous vous
êtes surveillés et en cas d' attaque
vous ne les voyez même bazar
while we're ce que nous avons vu dans le
scénario d'après le 11 septembre c'est
que dans le cas du pakistan la cia reçu
l'autorisation en tuer ils bombardent
des villages il y à des villages de
madras des maisons capable parfois il
déclare avoir supprimé un terroriste et
plus tard on voit en vie alors qu'ils
ont ils tué il m'avait fait tuer des
enfants pour le pays
faut pas fait pour le profit a aucune
comment pouvez-vous sourire
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur rt france pour 1h30 d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
émission vous vous en doutez
essentiellement consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus en france plus de 3000 décès
dont 418 de plus ces dernières 24 heures
dans les hôpitaux 44 milles 550 cas de
coronavirus confirmés dans le pays
et puis audition ce mercredi du premier
ministre et du ministre de la santé dans
le cadre de la mission d'information sur
le qui-vive 19 de l'assemblée nationale
elle a pour objet d'interroger sur les
mesures déjà prises ainsi que leurs
applications dans le monde comptabilise
désormais plus de 35 mille morts dont la
majorité en europe en hongrie viktor
orban renforce ses pouvoirs et peut
prolonger indéfiniment l'état d'urgence
outre atlantique un navire hôpital
militaire de 1000 lits est arrivé à new
york alors que la maladie se propage en
russie confinement généralisée pour la
population et fermeture des frontières
en syrie l'onu et l'union européenne
appelle à un cessez le feu pour faire
face à l'épidémie qui s'annonce
le fonds monétaire international estime
qu'une profonde récession en 2020 est un
fait acquis sur le vieux continent en
france alors que les petites et moyennes
entreprises sont touchées de plein fouet
par la crise sanitaire
le gouvernement a mis en place un fonds
de solidarité auxquelles elles pourront
à nouveau avoir accès en avril selon le
ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire
[Musique]
en france les derniers chiffres viennent
de tomber plus de 3000 décès duo kobe de
10,9 dont à 418 ces dernières 24 heures
dans les hôpitaux soit la plus forte
augmentation en nombre sur une journée
depuis le début de l'épidémie à près de
21 mille personnes sont actuellement
hospitalisées dont elle 50000 56 en
réanimation 34% d'entre elles ont moins
de 60 ans plus de 20000 postes par jour
vous pouvoir être fait avant la fin de
la semaine a annoncé ce soir jérôme
salomon le directeur général de la santé
lors du point presse quotidien
le ministère de la santé qui compte
doubler à dix mille le nombre de lits en
réanimation à les ehpad
confronté notamment à la pénurie de
masques de protection dans les
établissements pour seniors le
coronavirus fait des ravages à les
maisons de retraite redoutent la mort de
cent mille personnes âgées a malgré les
annonces ce week-end du ministre de la
santé ou du révérend pour ces structures
le personnel soignant se sent démuni
ciel il affame ouzou lionel girard et
quentin mauclair malika belarbi et aides
soignantes depuis 25 ans dans le centre
de long séjour d abondance
comme la plupart du personnel c'est au
début de la crise qu'elle a découvert
effaré que la france ne disposait pas du
stock de protection nécessaires pour
faire face à l'épidémie manqué de masque
pendant le début du récit au niveau du
confinement
pratiquement tous les soignants des
ehpad n'avait pas de maths parce qu'on a
pensé que c'était inutile au niveau
matériel au niveau du savon
hydroalcoolique certains établissements
n'avaient y en a qui en avait pas il n'y
avait pas aussi une absence de gand là
alors je vous dis pas des sourds blues
il y en a aujourd'hui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en a pas et on a très peu
les établissements sont complètement là
ils sont un peu tout sans stress parce
qu'ils sont au niveau tendue au niveau
du matériel ce que dans d'ici la fin la
semaine prochaine en aura plus rien ce
qui la révolte avant tout c'est le
manque d'anticipation des autorités
sanitaires
mon reproche c'est au niveau d'aidé du
gouvernement qui n'a pas pris à temps
la commande n'a pas pris en temps le le
problème sur locaux vides 19 et qui met
aujourd'hui nos établissements en
difficulté parce que les mesures elles
ont pas été prise sans en amant et le
virus circule aujourd'hui elle
s'inquiète pour cette population
vulnérable dont elle est en charge
nous avons des cas l'intérieur de kovy
19 qui nous inquiète parce
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes âgées qui
sont des personnes vulnérables avec des
polypathologies pour
il y aura malheureusement beaucoup de
décès moi je le souhaite pas mais je
pense que l'on part sur cette route là
une inquiétude que partage ludovic
milice dont la mère est dans un
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées y tenons là mais
landreau qu'elle allait clairement qu'il
ya trop de personnages et qui peuvent
pas de passer déplaise à tous pourquoi
le couple comme ça un peu comme la
france on est un des pays les plus
puissants au monde alors que l'épidémie
n'a pas encore atteint son pic
le personnel soignant poursuit ses
efforts entre peur et sens du devoir
il me réclame une action rapide des
autorités face à ce qui se profile comme
une véritable catastrophe sanitaire et
humaine et pour en contrer la pandémie
elle ihe méditerranée infections permet
à ceux qui le souhaitent de se faire
dépister les marins pompiers sont
mobilisés depuis jeudi devant
l'établissement marseille a dirigé par
le professeur didier raoul l'institut
peut effectuer jusqu'à 2500 tests
quotidiens sur des personnes avec ou
sans symptômes
ah les soldats du feu ont établi un
poste médical
le rassemblement est inévitable et par
contre les distances de sécurité sont là
sont présentes et sont recommandés
régulièrement quand on monte de la files
d'attentes pour le rappeler qu'il faut
garder une distance de m entre eux et
puis les personnes dont les équipes du
masque qu'il ya chez nous a donné notre
rôle plutôt là et pédagogiques
c'est-à-dire d'informer les gens que
tout le monde va être testée puisque
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit qu'ils
allaient passer par notre notre table
pour être orientés et après aux
alentours de 17h 18h on essaie d'évaluer
par rapport à la file d'attenté des gens
qui sont susceptibles de passer et après
sinon on conseille aux gens de revenir
le lendemain parce qu'ils ne pourront
pas passer dans la soirée alors
l'hôpital de la timone c'est là où
officie l'équipe du professeur didier
raoult est à l'origine du traitement
hydroxy chloroquine azithromycine remède
miracle ou faux espoirs le débat
continue en france alors que le
traitement est autorisé dans les
hôpitaux américains depuis hier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc j'avais
[Musique]
et pour revenir sur la situation
sanitaire en france est la question de
la prescription de claudine nous sommes
avec renaud muselier président les
républicains de la région provence alpes
côte d'azur est également médecin
renaud muselier bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
commencer peut être une réaction à ces
chiffres plus de 3000 morts en france
désormais 4 118 décès enregistrés ces
dernières 24 heures hier il y avait 2
192 morts à quelle est votre réaction à
ces derniers chiffres qui viennent de
tomber
c'était quelque part et vue c'est à dire
que depuis que nous trouvons notre pays
a été attaqué par le grand test dans la
région car il n'est pas rare que
monsieur robert médecin urgentiste comme
moi nous sommes parfaitement au courant
de l'évolution
aujourd'hui c'est une partie la france
qui est touchée avec véronal avec from
all france comptait bien sur l'île de
france la corse nous l'occitanie où on
voit une montée impression de 7e temps
béni de cette épidémie qui est
meurtrière et donc ça va continuer on a
également appris aujourd'hui est le
premier ministre sera entendu mercredi
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sur le kobe de 19 de
l'assemblée nationale qu'en attendez
vous sauf que le gouvernement une
réunification le complexe et je trouve
que c'est très bien que le premier
ministre continue d'avoir un échange ale
au parlement de façon à ce qu'il y ait
une démocratie qui continuent à
fonctionner et on ne soit plus qu'on ne
soit pas immédiatement mais souhaitait
noir même l'un des populaires et la
démocratie avec des parlementaires ou
que l'exercice qui a été fait par le
premier ministre avec monsieur véran
explicative lien avant-hier a été je
trouve pédago ils ont trouvé le bon ton
ils ont expliqué les jt et de toute
façon il y aura à l'issue de cette scène
de ce drame humain
médical économique puisque en fait nous
sommes confrontés à de crise les crises
sanitaires une crise économique que
donnent les deux sports mais après il y
aura bien entendu comme toujours dans
une démocratie
des explications qui devront être
données est prise pour ma part je suis
avec l'ensemble des régions de france
puisque je suis président de
l'association des régions de france
nous sommes 0 polémique nous sommes sur
nos territoires a arrêté ces deux crises
majeures une décision de faire mieux et
derrière vous pourrez constater qu'il ya
une solidarité interrégionale puisque
des patients du nantais sont été
accueillie dans un premier temps dans
l'es6 je prends ça comme mesure des
accords sont arrêtés et comme accueilli
bien monde y est comme aujourd'hui la
nouvelle aquitaine où l'abattage croit
les pays de la loire
il ya une solidarité régionale
interrégionale katché le nécessaire et
donc travailler en ce sens une façon
désengorger les réanimations apaisé
quelque sorte le personnel soignant qui
est en première ligne et qui souffre
énormément de façon à ce que l'on se
partage cette affaire que nous vivons au
quotidien nos régions respectives
alors vous êtes également membre du
conseil d'administration de liège une
marseille vous connaissez bien le
professeur raoul qu il fait l'objet
toutes les passions ce moment certains
l'ont qualifié de charlot d'autres lui
disent carrément je cite de fermer sa
gueule qui est-il vraiment comment le
décrire d'abord tout ceci est
considérablement excessif celui qui lui
a parlé comme ça et monsieur cohn-bendit
mais qui reçu cohn bendit qui part de
drogue sont en belgique mais parler
comme ça un scientifique qui est classé
plusieurs fois numéro un au monde qui a
créé lee h et je ne crois pas que
monsieur cohn bendit sont adaptés ont
tenté ce genre de remarque d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'offres au lieu de se taire et
laisser les scientifiques se parler
entre eux plutôt que dalle
ajoutez de l' angoisse de l'espoir avec
de la haine tout ça n'a aucun sens dans
une période de crise comme celle que
nous vivons aujourd'hui est un
établissement qui a été créée par le
professeur out qui dispose de 800
collaborateurs avec 200 chercheurs qui
est un établissement dans lequel on peut
faire des prélèvements des soins
traitements une hospitalisation et de la
recherche
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
autant de recherche dans cet
établissement qui est dans les hôpitaux
de marseille collé à la faculté et donc
nous avons avec le professeur a loupé
une sommité mondiale de qui méritent
considération
attention et des bases scientifiques cet
interlocuteur un produit de la séance
qui est un vrai scientifique qui avait
parlé à même des preuves à ses
explications qu'ils peuvent être
contestées en termes de méthodologie par
la communauté scientifique mais en tout
cas tout ce qu'il dit à son endroit
défavorable et souvent plutôt maîtrisant
alors que nous avons là un des barques
de recherche scientifique a emmené son
par les scientifiques entre moi je suis
médecin je sois en effet je suis pas
salé confrontées à un besoin de la
population d'une part d'être dépisté
nous pouvons créer avec le professeur
out qui fait une grosse bourde 15% du
tout dépistage français et parallèlement
à ça parce qu'elle est noire aujourd'hui
la seule piste qui existe à peu près qui
est la grande discussion mondiale
peut-être qu'il en sortira porte
mais aujourd'hui un taux de l'apéritif
qui n'est jamais que les rives de la
nive active donc tout le débat qui fait
sur les complexités à fallait alors vous
plaît messieurs n'a pas lieu d'être
justement renaud muselier sur cette
question de la chloroquine pour soigner
des malades atteints du coc vie 19
il y a les usa le maroc le sénégal qui
ont donné leur accord pour sa
distribution et sa prescription pourrait
sous certaines conditions mais pas
encore en france on veut laisser du
temps à l'étude est ce que la france est
à contre-courant par rapport au reste du
monde qu'est ce que cela vous inspire
otez moi je suis pas en train de
comparer des sorties publiques
j'aime beaucoup les pays du nord mais je
crois pas que ce soit les leaders
mondiaux dans ce qui concerne la la le
traitement les nourrir l'infectiologie
parlez moi ça les américains ont pris
une décision qui est de la bascule dans
leurs hôpitaux ils se sont précipités
je suis passionné ailleurs comme ce
monsieur le président trompe dit du bien
du professeur out of sight
fondamentalement les travaux du
professeur woods donc je sais c'est un
ballon qui tourne à l'hystérie
collective du mondial il ya autour d'un
problème est assez simple finalement
c'est que nous sommes en phase de
populations qui sont inquiètes
angoissé et qui incontestablement ont
besoin d'avoir quelque chose qui peut
marcher et quelque chose qui ne nuit pas
et ce traitement
c'est le cas et il a fait un premier
test sur 24 malades maintenant 80 bon
moi ici à la région provence alpes côte
d'azur
nous avons eu quatre membres de ma
famille qui a été soigné à l'accord
utile
j'en ai six mon équipe direct rapprocher
à la région j'ai 19 collaborateurs toute
la région étaient fermées
confiné ils sont tous allés se faire
dépister pour ceux qui étaient proches
et aujourd'hui de tous été traités
rappelé guy léger 000 malades
le taux de géologie est tombé donc une
personne à partir mais animations ce qui
veut dire que quand même ça va à
l'encontre des autres statistiques des
autres hôpitaux français en réanimation
maintenant il est très difficile pour
monsieur le ministre la santé d'arriver
à a donné raison professeur out contre
soi disant des sociétés ce alors qu'ils
sont farouchement opposés et on se
retrouve là avec l'affrontement que les
français ne veulent pas entendre et
d'aucune décision qu'il se manquera pas
d'arriver puisque des études sur fès
savez je connais bien les scientifiques
dans ces études là on trouve pas le
remède magique d'un coup et d'ailleurs
je me suis rendue en jamaïque se
remettre magique
c'était une piste sérieuse qui
travaillent dans le monde entier et qui
donnent des fruits
incontestablement donc les tests ils
vont enlever bondir sa marque donne pas
de situation ça marche pas dans d'autres
en tout cas quelqu'un ça tue quelqu'un
au concours alors vous parlez d'une
population angoissée des français envoie
ses des français qui ont de moins en
moins confiance dans le gouvernement
pour faire face à la crise du
coronavirus la confiance ça continue de
baisser mois 10 points en une semaine et
devient nettement minoritaire selon un
sondage opinionway diffusé ce lundi la
gestion de crise de la part du
gouvernement
vous la jugez comment vous coûter en
tout cas je ne porterai pas de jugement
et je suis solidaire loin j'étais une
jeune meneur j'ai géré quand j'étais aux
affaires étrangères la crise de sharm el
sheikh dans l'avion est tombé et qu'on
ne savait pas ce tintin c'était un
accident j'ai géré la crise du tsunami
vous savez gérer la crise que vous les
mains c'est quelque chose de très
difficile
et donc je pense qu'il y aura après des
questions à se poser pour savoir dans
quel état et autres appareils de santé
pourquoi on est à l'absence d'un certain
nombre de consuegra bruno ménard et donc
ces questions-là creuseront ap
aujourd'hui on est dans des décisions
d'urgence le gouvernement fait ce qu'il
peut avec ce qu'il a bien entendu il est
toujours difficile d'anticiper
l'imprévisible est donc dans cette
situation là je trouve que l'effort de
pédagogie ou entre les images qui a été
fait cette semaine par le premier
ministre est tout à fait remarquable la
gestion sur le plan économique de la
crise économique ce que l'autorité de
monsieur le maire est plutôt très
positive à l'emploi bien entendu
discuter les montants et les modalités
mais maintenant il ya une prise de
conscience réelle avec des réponses qui
sont opérés précise et qui sont toujours
très difficiles à prendre et en tout cas
ce n'est pas leur
nick est donc pour ma part h pas chez un
républicain je suis pas mais je suis un
ancien urgentiste je sais quand il ya
des problèmes aussi importants et
difficiles à 30,4 calme fait opposés il
faut être serein qu'il faut garder la
tête froide et j'entends beaucoup trop
de commentaires de gens qui n'ont jamais
dirigé jamais gouverné n'ont jamais
soigné et qu'ils ne sont que dans le
commentaire d'un commentaire et de bons
n'a pas gêné rentre pas dans ce dimanche
alors il ya aussi vous en parliez à la
question les masques ce qui suscite des
interrogations la semaine dernière la
région sud avait fait savoir dans un
communiqué qu'elle venait de commander
quatre millions de masques livrable sous
dix jours afin de lutter contre
l'épidémie dit coronavirus aujourd'hui
dans un communiqué on apprend que les
masques seraient livrés la semaine
prochaine quand précisément les
professionnels vont pouvoir bénéficier
rapidement de masques dans votre région
nous avons fait assez vite pour la
commande le paiement la fabrication
puisque l'autorisation
dans le cas de la loi d'urgence qui
était passé entre l'assemblée et le
sénat samedi nous a permis de faire la
commande sur un industriel chinois he et
cette commande avec le lille alain penin
a été réalisée c'est-à-dire que les
masques seront fabriqués et en attente
aujourd'hui en schyle des difficultés
que nous rencontrons c'est la cheminée
de vianne avoir engagé pour deux soirs
et dans cet acheminement commission
parce que nous avons nous les pressions
de france en fait avec l'ensemble des
prud'hommes région commandé près de 60
millions de masques pour nos régions
respectives
sauf que ce matin lors de sur le tarmac
en chine une commande française a été
achetée par les américains cash sur le
tarmac est l'avion qui devait venir en
france est partie directement en aux
états unis donc devant ces problèmes
large c'est en train de sécuriser la
la marchandise de façon à ce que il ça
passe par ces vagues et la filiale
mondiale dépendant de cma-cgm qui est le
programmateur mondiale de façon à ce que
cette marchandise ne soit pas saisie ou
achetés par d'autres sur le tarmac et
donc je vous donnerai la précise dans le
courant de la semaine
alors pour conclure renaud muselier vous
nous l'avez dit vous êtes médecin de
profession ancien des hôpitaux de paris
bernard jomier sénateurs et médecin a
rejoint lui l'hôpital de melun pour
soigner les malades du coït 19 est ce
que c'est quelque chose à laquelle vous
avez songé je suis médecin mais je suis
moi j'aime marseille 1 donc je suis moi
je suis dépendent les hôpitaux de
marseille
mais j'ai une autre casquette ceci
médecin mais je dirige je suis d' acte
médical d'un établissement de
rééducation fonctionnelle et de roues
que nous avons je suis toujours médecin
et je suis tous les jours à la clinique
pour m'occuper des patients nous
sommes-nous hospitalisation privée
nous avons mis en place le plan avec la
rs le plan blanc nous avons libéré 30%
de nos vies pour faire en sorte qu'une
fluidité sur la filière hospitalière
entre le samu là l'urgence les
réanimations les services hospitaliers
coville ou deux ans et la libération
délire la balle et nous sommes
positionnés sur cette filière pour
fluidifier et donc j'ai repris mon mari
blanchi
merci beaucoup renaud muselier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes président les républicains de
la région provence alpes côte d'azur et
vous
nous le dira médecin avec cette pandémie
de nombreuses professions doivent
s'adapter et c'est le cas des avocats
suite aux ordonnance fixant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire à la justice voit
son fonctionnement modifié fini les
procès au tribunal
la visioconférence doit être privilégiée
autre changement à la suspension de la
prescription de l'action publique et de
l'exécution des peines ou
l'élargissement du recours au juge
unique pour les audiences
correctionnelles et pour parler de cette
activité judiciaire en plein état
d'urgence sanitaire est en plein
confinement nous sommes avec christian
saint-palais avocat et président de
l'association à des avocats pénalistes
christian saint-palais bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors à l'instauration d'un état
d'urgence sanitaire bouleverse on lisait
profondément la justice notamment le
droit des justiciables concrètement
qu'est ce qui change pour eux dans ce
contexte d'état d'urgence sanitaire mais
concrètement la plupart des procès sont
interrompus ce qui était en cours à ce
qu'ils étaient étalés sur plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois comme le
procès du médiator c'est un contenu et
il devrait reprendre le 1er juin tout ce
qui était programmé pour une après midi
une journée ou deux jours et pour
l'essentiel dès lors que ce n'est pas
considéré comme urgent suspendu reporter
mais il reste bien sûr au pénal des
affaires qui sont celles aux gens qu en
tout cas par les procureurs de la
république et qui justifie soit des
gardes à vue
c'est à dire des auditions au sein des
commissariats soit des audiences qui
sont des audiences de comparution
immédiate
ou alors des audiences qui ont pour
objet des juges et des faits qui sont
estimés grave est reproché à des
personnes qui sont en prison et qui sont
donc jugés soit extraite de la prison
jusqu'au tribunal soit par
visioconférence donc il ya peu
d'audience mais il reste deux audiences
les avocats pénalistes sont toujours sur
le terrain qu'en ce moment
mais en quoi cette disparition
général 1 d'audience publique oral et
contradictoire inquiète votre profession
alors je crois dire c'est que quand même
désordre dans une ordonnance a été pris
dans matière pénale qui est très
contesté par les pénalistes parce que
incontestablement elle porte atteinte
aux libertés fondamentales
il est tout à fait normal que dans une
circonstance particulière que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui est tout à fait
exceptionnel il est tout à fait normal
qu'on est un petit aménagement de l'état
de droit
la question qui se pose de ce raid de la
mesure vous avez dit tout à l'heure dans
votre présentation que on envisager que
la collégialité sont abandonnés et qu'on
ait recours au chili que c'est vrai que
l'ordonnancé prévoit qu'on ne pourra y
avoir recours très régulièrement est
prévue la visioconférence c'est une
mesure exceptionnelle pour ligier au
pénal je dis que effectivement il peut
être nécessaire d'y avoir recours actuel
dont tellement on veut craindre la
contamination par le transfert des uns
et des autres et la fréquentation des
lieux tube we on peut avoir recours à
des mesures exceptionnelles en une
occasion d'exceptionnel mais là ce qui
peut heurter c'est le cul nu toutes les
mesures dérogatoires qui sont que nous
sommes dans un état de droit qui est
quand même très contrainte et nous avons
eu en plus des dispositions relatives à
la détention provisoire c'est à dire les
gens qui ne sont pas encore au succès
qui sont en détention provisoire de
manière exceptionnelle dans l' attente
de leur procès et pour lesquelles on a
augmenté la durée de cette détention
provisoire jusqu'à six mois pour
certaines d'affaires et nous avons
découvert à la publication d'une
circulaire d'avant-hier que des notions
ce qui était déjà organisé pour statuer
sur la prolongation de cette détention
provisoire ces auditions se sont
empilées par la circulaire alors c'est à
dire que nous avons régularisé des
recours ou et que le conseil d'état va
être saisi dans les tout prochains jours
pour statuer sur la légalité de cette
ordonnance
alors on a bien compris à cette question
de négation des droits de la défense
pour conclure qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous pour préserver ce droit de
la défense dans la situation actuelle
jeudi d'avoir que les avocats sont
toujours présents et qu'il faut
organiser des conditions sanitaires
permettant à tous les avocats de
descendre dans des conditions qui
protègent les justiciables et qui
protège le d'avocats venus aujourd'hui
vous n'avez dans les tribunaux aucun
masque aucun gant et fort peu de zèle
qui est distribué
nous avons besoin d'entretien
confidentiel pendant la garde à vue et
avant les audiences de comparution
immédiate ce que nous reprochons
actuellement à la fin chefs de
juridiction et des pannes est de ne pas
être à disposition des avocats des
pièces permettant la sécurité de
l'entretien vous savez que le tribunal
de paris est un tribunal et non c'était
bien d'être construit c'est un vaisseau
qui aujourd'hui est ville on ne peut pas
prétendre qu'il n'y a pas de salle
suffisantes pour organiser des
entretiens confidentiels et permettre la
sécurité des justiciables et bien
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
le bâtonnier a été obligé de sultan pour
les commissions d'office et il n'y a pas
d'avocats pour les étables les plus
faibles parce que nous n'avons pas des
conditions de sécurité optimales pour
les justiciables à ce corps de quelque
chose qu'il faut absolument dénoncé il
est possible de défendre dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles et c'est
ce que nous demandons
merci beaucoup christian saint-palais
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat et
président de l'association des avocats
pénalistes dans quelques instants nous
partirons en allemagne elle choisi une
stratégie proche de celle prônée par la
corée du sud au début de l'épidémie
c'est à dire des tests massif jusqu'à
500 milles sont pratiqués chaque semaine
puis direction la syrie qui a adopté une
batterie de mesures pour lutter contre
la propagation du coït 19 dans un pays
déjà dévasté à part à neuf ans de guerre
on revient à tout de suite rester avec
nous sur rt france
[Musique]
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un de tout à
fait précis je vous le dirai déjà à
paris sans prétention qu aux jo ne
pouvait faire tous les kilomètres vous
devrez pas quelqu'un on ne tourne on en
plein mois de novembre à bien comme ça
j'aime tous mes sauf l'anonymat
l'anonyme avait surmonté ce poids tu
viens de chez toi tu vas au boulot tu
reviens personne a dit monsieur ou
madame vous êtes et les gonflements la
vie est belle en couleurs pourquoi
diable bleu vous beaucoup
vous allez tous au noir bleu marine j'ai
dû nous c'est pas possible ça sert à
rien l'habille le sapeur fait jouer à
l'ebit son premier rôle qui ne devait
pas cessé d'être un vecteur de
communication
mais la sape pas cessé de vivre ensemble
via la bi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que le sport n'est pas raciste
mais ce qu'il ya du racisme dans le
milieu du sport effectivement inscrits
de saint son emblème du racisme dans le
sport
la ministre peut très bien saisir le
parquet elle ne le fait pas retourner
dans le discours on est dans la fassad
una l'apparence un moment je suis pour
la conditionnalité vous ne voulez pas
tenir compte des valeurs républicaines
et bien vous n'aurez pas l'argent de la
république et vous verrez qu'à ce moment
là croyez-moi les clubs sportifs
prendront les mesures adéquates il faut
en fait que la société civile prennent
le sujet à bras le corps pour
qu'aujourd'hui ces phénomènes qui sont
les phénomènes sociétaux commence à
déranger tout le monde ira si c'est
comme la plus je peux pas empêcher la
pluie mais je peux avoir un parapluie on
ne peut pas empêcher les racistes de
raciste et xénophobe d'être homophobe
on peut avoir des mesures qui protègent
les victimes c'est ça qui était
sectionné
[Musique]
oh
ils se sauvent dès qu on les prévient
que quelqu'un monte ici
année ils exploitent les populations
autochtones
ad il les paye pour qu'il coupe les
arbres crise
bon c'est pour la plupart des
politiciens sont complaisants boire sont
directement impliqués
tout à coup un homme est entré en
courant et m'a dit qu'on avait tiré sur
gerry
j'ai dit que j'entrerai de toute façon
même s'il ne me laissait pas faire même
s'il me tirait dessus on se moque de
leur argent
même s'il propose de nous payer des
millions chaque jour de notre vie nous
n'allons pas vendre notre terre à ces
entreprises
même s'ils nous tuent tous nous ne
partirons pas
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france il est
20h30 heure française cette émission
vous vous en doutez largement consacrée
à la crise du cornât virus dans le monde
plus de 400 mille cas de coronavirus
désormais comptabilisés en europe et
plus de 26 mille morts l italie pays le
plus touché en europe a enregistré un
bilan 812 morts ces dernières 24 heures
mais les signes encourageants à la
hausse des nouveaux cas positifs ont
recensé n'a jamais été aussi faible pour
la première fois depuis le début de la
pandémie dans le pays le nombre de
personnes actuellement positive en
lombardie c'est la région avec le plus
grand nombre de cas a baissé à l'espagne
deuxième pays européen le plus touché
enregistre également une légère baisse
du nombre de morts elles les autorités
ont annoncé 800 12 décès ce lundi contre
838 dimanche les détails avec robin pu
elle une minute de silence dans les rues
de madrid l'espagne a rendu hommage aux
nombreuses personnes décédées à cause du
coronavirus le pays est durement touché
par l'épidémie
l'espagne est en effet le troisième
foyer d'infection monde derrière
l'italie et les états unis
malgré un bilan humain toujours très
lourd les premiers effets du confinement
de la population imposé il y a deux
semaines semble se faire ressentir
les autorités ont ainsi souligné le
ralentissement continu depuis le 25 mars
de l'augmentation du nombre de morts les
données que nous avons annoncé ces
derniers jours et surtout aujourd'hui
offre une lueur d'espoir en termes de
stabilisation avec le début d'un
ralentissement de la courbe
cela doit toujours être pris avec la
plus grande prudence car il s'agit d'une
crise dynamique et les données peuvent
évoluer les 16000 780 personnes qui ont
déjà guéri offre également une lueur
d'espoir mais la situation reste
toujours très critique principale
préoccupation la saturation des hôpitaux
les professionnels de santé et un lourd
tribut dans la lutte contre le coc vie
19 plus de 12000 soignants espagnols
sont infectées par le virus
pour faire face à l'afflux de malades le
gouvernement a demandé à l'armée d'
installer
un hôpital de campagne à l'extérieur de
l'un des principaux centres hospitaliers
de la capitale une aide appréciée par
les médecins mais qui reste encore
insuffisante
nous espérons qu'avec ce qui est en
train de faire l'armée comme lorsqu ils
emmènent les patients à l'hôpital de
campagne du centre de conférence nous
pourront atténuer la gravité de la
situation
nous espérons que cela se terminera
bientôt que les fusils romieu et que
tous ceux qui sont malades iront mieux
bien que dans la salle d'attenté il ya
40 personnes malades
c'est une situation qui aurait pu être
évitée afin de freiner la propagation du
virus
le gouvernement de pedro sanchez a
décidé de durcir les conditions du
confinement déjà prolongé jusqu'au 11
avril notamment en surveillant les
déplacements tous les salariés
travaillant dans des secteurs non
essentiels devront rester chez eux
durant deux semaines à partir de ce
lundi
et puis en allemagne dans ce contexte de
coronavirus thomass schefer le ministre
des finances de hesse s'est suicidé
profondément inquiets des conséquences
du coc vite 19 sur l'économie le
ministre a mis fin à ses jours il a été
retrouvé mort samedi sur les rails d'une
ligne de train à grande vitesse dans la
ville de hockey qui m'amène monsieur
schaeffer était responsable depuis dix
ans des finances de cette région où se
trouve francfort le centre financier
allemand siège de la banque centrale
européenne et deux grandes banques
allemandes et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis munich avec peter miss
tron député f des deux munich c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
peter bistrol merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors hier le
ministre de l'économie on le disait en
du land de hesse monsieur scheffer s'est
donné la mort il travaillait d'ailleurs
sur les conséquences économiques de
cette pandémie
comment les allemands ont réagi à cette
nouvelle
way we have déplaît profondément affecté
par ce suicide bien sûr nous pensons
fortement sa famille pour revenir sur
cette crise de coronavirus que traverse
le monde entier et l'allemagne comment
vous interpréter les bonnes statistiques
de votre pays je rappelle que
l'allemagne compte aujourd'hui près de
cinquante huit mille cas et 1 455 décès
concernant le coronavirus ces chiffres
sont moins importants qu'en france
est-ce que selon vous ils sont liés à
cette stratégie le sud coréenne choisi
par votre pays
je ne vais pas de munich
mais je suis à 500 m
cet hôpital très célèbre de loïc la
première personne contaminée par le
virus
en europe a été hospitalisé il
s'agissait d'un chinois est un employé
d'une industrie d'une entreprise
chinoise
cela explique pourquoi nous avons
beaucoup de personnes contaminées qui
sont très jeunes et très peu de décès le
premier groupe de personnes contaminées
étaient dans l'industrie automobile et
le second groupe c'était des personnes
qui ont été contaminées après être parti
ce qui est en autriche pendant les
vacances ce sont des personnes jeunes
qui ont été contaminés et peu d'entre
elles sont mortes la plupart des
personnes mortes ont plus de 80 ans est
ce que cette stratégie de dépistage
massif 1 mise en place en allemagne
est ce qu'elle est soutenu par tous les
partis politiques du pays les uns s'agit
pas d'un dépistage de masse
il s'agit plutôt que le gouvernement
allemand au contraire a pris beaucoup de
temps avant de réagir il a fallu
plusieurs du professionnel fin de
l'année dernière on savait déjà depuis
la chine que le corps n'était restée
très dangereux nous avons constaté les
premières contaminations au début
janvier au gouvernement ne réagissait
pas
au cours des deux dernières semaines le
gouvernement a surréagi mohmmad il de
proposer les premiers moments du
cannabis mais ma position votre propre
parti à tous soutenir l'action du
gouvernement de tous les actes de
charité il s'agit de protéger une boîte
propre population envers les élections à
d'autres notamment
rencontre était perçue des libertés
personnelles sociales
examinons donc de très près l'action du
gouvernement je nous vous disons que
toutes ces restrictions devraient être
très limité dans le temps devrait durer
peut-être quatre semaines et ensuite il
faudrait réévaluer la situation afin de
s'assurer que les mesures sont
acceptables que il y a des conséquences
économiques à très lourdes il n'est pas
bon pour l'économie allemande
et ce n'est pas bon pour l'économie
européenne selon vous sur la question
des chiffres à en allemagne est ce que
il y à une transparence totale sur la
diffusion de ces données
ah ouais nice et je ne parlerai pas de
transparence
on dirait que quelqu'un d'autre les
cacher quelque chose à ce que kate
sommes en phase iib fier certains je
dirais qu'il est très difficile de
trouver les noms de la statistique
car certaines statistiques disent qu'un
certain nombre de personnes sont mortes
dos mais ne savait pas dû qu'à une ombre
est mort ça directement ou six autres
personnes sont mortes d'autres causes
puis ont été contaminés avec le corps
navires et enfin ne savons pas quel est
le nombre de personnes mortes
directement des conséquences de leur
impulsion avec les coronavirus ton
statistiques ne sont pas claires de ce
point de vue nous mêmes ne sommes pas
certains du nombre de personnes sont
véritablement mortes des conséquences
directes du cornât virus alors pour
conclure on a vu l'allemagne venir en
aide à la france pour prendre en charge
des malades
est ce que cela montre une europe enfin
solidaire en matière de santé
dernière question est vraiment la
question la plus importante voire les
grands problèmes auxquels faisait face
union européenne avant même la crise du
corps navires us open et est en pleine
crise penser autre existe 50 us l'un des
plus importants pays de l'union la
quitter si nous sommes confrontés à une
crise de l'euro très importante de
nombreux pays tels que l'italie
l'espagne le portugal la grèce sont des
problèmes économiques très importants et
à cela s'ajoute la crise tu coronavirus
il est primordial maintenant de faire
preuve de solidarité
et dire que nous nous tenons la
commission européenne l'union européenne
ne font rien la commission européenne
nous en sommes très critiques
il est très important que les pays
soient solidaires et s'entraident
merci beaucoup peter bistrot d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député ard de munich
et puis en russie vladimir poutine
demande à la population de se confiner
chez elles le pays qui vient de fermer
ses frontières seuls sont autorisés les
déplacements professionnels à médicaux
ou les sorties pour se ravitailler
depuis une semaine les plus de 65 ans
était soumis un confinement partiels le
président russe vladimir poutine s'est
entretenu avec son homologue américain
donald trump par téléphone ils ont
évoqué la possibilité d'une coopération
sur l'épidémie et le pétrole
explications avec notre correspondant en
russie antoine cléroux cela fait
plusieurs jours qu'il s'y prépare en
tout cas sans compter que la population
russe suit de très près l'évolution de
la situation en europe
c'est donc à moscou que les mesures sont
les plus strictes ou un confinement de
la population est adoptée depuis ce
matin
travail généralisé distances sociales
d'au moins un mètre cinquante et bien
sûr interdiction de quitter le domicile
mises à part quelques exceptions comme à
la pharmacie ou au magasin le plus
proche le président russe s'est
d'ailleurs exprimé aujourd'hui pour
encourager la population pour lui dire
que cette mesure est juste et nécessaire
qu'il est donc important de la respectée
et écoutée et mais il est très important
actuellement killian opérations entre
les structures locales régionales et
fédérales fois qu'elle travaille de
manière cohérente et préventive il ne
faut pas se laisser aller à la
présomption mais agir dans le calme et
l'assurance queen ou vilaine et nadio
gérard dufaud aussi que les gens soient
toujours informé objectif arrière de
l'évolution de la situation et des
mesures prises et c'est la meilleure
réponse aux provocations et les ragots
stupide et spéculations malveillantes et
je m'adresse à vous ils représentent en
deuxième les niveaux du pouvoir
4c'est droite qui sont ok ils ont admiré
nedum chaises et coire et brics à vittel
investir ou le niveau reste nous devons
agir de façon raisonnable et
professionnels cette approche nous a
aidés à gagner du temps et à limiter la
propagation explosive du corona les rues
six dernières semaines
car elle est retournée une fillette
s'est pris de douche initial et si les
encouragements ne suffise pas le
gouvernement établit tout un barème des
amendes des amants qui commence à partir
de 15 mille roubles soit à peu près 170
euros
c'est donc tout un lot de mesures qui
ressemble au final de plus en plus à la
situation actuellement en vigueur en
france
alors que le nombre de contaminations en
russie a atteint 1834 cas pour 10 morts
en syrie maintenant on a appris hier
et le tout premier décès lié au qu'ovide
19 9 autres quarts ont été
officiellement recensés
après l'onu l'union européenne a appelé
hier à un cessez le feu dans le pays
dans la province d'idlib et ses environs
il ya urgence
3 millions de syriens tentent de
survivre les précisions des labbes
médias
dans cette usine de la ville d'idlib des
femmes et des hommes produisent à la
main des masques de protection
objectif répondre à la forte demande et
éviter d'importer des masques hors de
prix en raison de la propagation du
coronavirus qui arrivent dans les
régions du nord de la syrie
les masques étaient très demandés à tous
les points de passage avec damas ont été
fermées par conséquent ne recevons plus
de produits de premiers soins on est de
masquer ce qui entraîne une forte
demande et va commencer à produire des
masques ici à la main 50 ouvrières et
ouvriers travaillent dans l' usine avec
des enfants qui viennent prêter main
forte au quotidien ce sont vingt mille
masques de protection qui sont produits
lorsque l'épidémie sera terminé je pense
que je pourrai dire que j'ai contribué à
ma manière même si c'était mineur en
fabriquant des masques en prévision de
la propagation du virus dans notre pays
des masques bienvenue dans la province
d'idlib où le co vide 19 menace tout
particulièrement ici le long de la
frontière turque plus d'un million de
civils s'entassent dans des camps des
femmes et des enfants en majorité qui
tente de survivre malgré un accès limité
aux soins et à l'eau potable un secteur
où des dizaines d'hôpitaux sont
désormais hors service en raison des
bombardements et des combats
le ministère syrien de la santé a donc
annoncé hier son premier décès lié au co
vie de 19 pour en parler nous sommes
avec nabil ans à qui il est médecin et
directeur d'hôpital à alep nabi lanta
qui bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on le
disait à la syrie annoncé hier un
premier décès lié au corona virus neuf
cas ont été confirmés par le ministère
syrien de la santé dans votre hôpital à
alep est ce que vous avez constaté une
arrivée de nouveaux patients avec des
symptômes qui pourraient être ceux du
comité 19 dans mon hôpital nous n'avons
eu aucun cas qui pourrait être le co
vite 19 mai dans d'autres hôpitaux à
alep et à damas et a eu des cas où
cliniquement et réduire
big man sur les scanners on pourrait
soupçonner que le malade soit atteint
par le cos vite 19
malheureusement les tests qui sont
effectués tous dans les laboratoires du
ministère de la santé deviennent
négatifs il n'y a que neuf cas qui ont
été déclarés en syrie mais nous les
médecins nous avons l'impression qu'il
ya davantage de cas que les neuf déclaré
ça veut dire que est-ce que vous dans
votre hôpital vous avez la possibilité
de tester les patients nous allons tous
les tests sont envoyés à damas au
laboratoire central du ministère de la
santé où les tests sont effectués
donc nous ne vont pas le moyen de tester
les malades mais nous avons les moyens
de faire des scanners des poumons et
d'examiner les malades et nous avons
l'impression que certains malades qui
sont décédées d'affections pulmonaires
était finalement atteint par le cos vite
19 alors après neuf années de guerre
est-ce que vous avez les moyens de faire
face à une crise sanitaire comment est
ce que vous vous y préparer ben
justement on sur paypal par des mesures
préventives en portant les masques en
portant des gants en utilisant les
désinfectants en solutions mais s'il y
avait une épidémie majeure en syrie
comme il y en a en europe
la série n'a pas les moyens d'y faire
face à cause de la guerre à gand à cause
du manque de moyens je prends un ville
comme alex healy a uniquement milka de
covile 19 à alep qui est une ville de
deux millions d'habitants
ben il y aura 100 patients qui ont
besoin d'être admis aux soins intensifs
sous respiration assistée et nous
n'avons pas dans tout alep sens
appareil de respiration artificielle
donc c'est dire que il faut absolument
juguler l'épidémie faut absolument
prendre les mesures préventives
parce que nous n'avons pas les moyens de
faire face à une épidémie
si elle a lieu en syrie alors justement
le gouvernement syrien a adopté une
série de mesures pour lutter contre la
propagation notamment un couvre-feu en
soirée à l'interdiction de déplacement
entre province est la fermeture des
écoles et des universités jusqu'à la mi
avril
ces mesures sont elles bien respectés et
sont elles suffisantes les mesures sont
vraiment respecté à la lettre les la
population collabore dans ce sens d'une
manière exemplaire
maintenant est ce que ces mesures sont
suffisantes non parce que il faut tester
davantage de gens les surtout le
personnel soignant ou là les familles
des malades qui sont décédés ou chez qui
on soupçonne une atteinte par le cos
vide pour pouvoir me tarde en
confinement absolue les les porteurs du
virus
malheureusement les tests de dépistage
n'ont pas lieu que on ne dépiste que
enfin relevé les tests que comme malade
qu'on soupçonne être atteint du co lead
donc il faut davantage de dépistage ce
qui n'est pas le cas actuellement en
syrie parce que dans toute la syrie il
n'y a que trois mille 3000 200 kits de
dépistage donc on né peut dépister
actuellement que 3200 personnes lui le
ministère de la santé a déjà utilisé 300
kits il en reste 3 minutes ce qui est
vraiment insuffisant pour une population
du de 20 millions d'habitants
en tant que directeur d'hôpital comment
est ce que vous préparez avec le
ministère
de la santé à faire face à une
éventuelle propagation est ce que vous
avez des consignes particulières
non il n'est pas de consignes
particulières sauf avertir le ministère
de la santé
si nous fonctionnons qu'il y ait un cas
de covile déchets nous est alors donc
les équipes du ministère de la santé
vient de faire des prélèvements
nécessaires et les envois damas donc
c'est une centralisation des examens des
informations alors la pandémie en menace
en particulier les six millions et demi
de déplacés dans le pays comme l'ont
récemment rappelé les enquêteurs de
l'onu pour la syrie elle est là
l'inquiétude mais bien sûr mais les
enquêteurs de l'onu et même vous même
quand vous avez fait le reportage tout à
l'heure vous ne parlez qui joue que des
déplacés de la province d'idlib faut pas
oublier que dans le reste de la syrie
qui est sous l'autorité de l'état syrien
il y a 6 millions de déplacés internes
et il ya beaucoup qui vivent dans des
camps à l'intérieur de la syrie et qui
sont menacés eux aussi par une épidémie
éventuelles une dernière question pour
conclure à l'union européenne et l'onu
on le disait appels au cessez le feu
dans toute la syrie pour mettre une pour
permettre une meilleure réponse face à
la menace du corona virus c'est réaliste
aujourd'hui notamment dans la province
d'idlib dans tous les cas le cessez le
feu a lieu de facto depuis au moins
quatre semaines
depuis l'arrêt des combats
quand l'armée syrienne avait lancé une
offensive pour libérer une partie de la
province d'idlib dans tous les cas moi
je pense que l'union européenne et les
etats unis au lieu de demander un
cessez-le-feu
il ferait mieux de lever les sanctions
contre la syrie ces sanctions qui ont
vraiment ruiné la syrie et qui sont
vraiment un danger maintenant à cause de
l'épidémie
merci beaucoup d'habits lanta qui
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin et
directeur d'hôpital à alep à les
vénézuéliens aussi obligé de braver le
confinement en cause un accès réduit à
certains produits de première nécessité
un rationnement qui vient s'ajouter à la
grave crise économique largement
amplifié par les sanctions américaines
mais dsk fait face à la pandémie qui
touche plus d'une centaine de bénévoles
et lien le pays affiche des signes de
pénurie les mesures décrétées le 17 mars
par nicholas maduro n'empêche pas la
population de sortir à la fois à la
recherche de produits ménagers comme le
savon et la lessive mais également pour
de l'essence des marchandises de plus en
plus rare étant donné que le pays n'est
plus fournie convenablement les
vénézuéliens sont donc obligés de braver
le confinement
je suis allé dans plusieurs stations
essence et elles sont fermées où elles
ne m'ont pas aidé parce que je suis
médecin à rien seulement pour les
militaires dans plusieurs stations ils
m'ont dit seulement pour les militaires
j'ai présenté mes diplômes de l'école de
médecine est rien ils ne m'ont pas aidé
on ne peut pas laver nos vêtements parce
que l'eau n'arrive pas l'on comprend ici
c'est juste de l'eau pour l'essentiel la
douche et c'est tout car malheureusement
on n'a pas de citernes pour laver nos
vêtements ou pour le ménage en général
la semaine dernière caracas a reçu 55
tonnes des d'envoyer par la chine
une aide qui comprenait uniquement du
matériel médical notamment des kits de
test rapide et des médicaments
cinq cent mille kits de test rapide sont
arrivés les premiers 500 mille kits de
test rapide pour l'offensive heures la
prochaine étape pour nous est de
contrôler et de prévenir le coït 19 face
à la crise sanitaire
le président vénézuélien mise sur une
quarantaine sociale collective et
volontaire nicolás maduro multiplier les
échanges avec l'extérieur afin de
récolter des soutiens précieux dans sa
lutte contre le coronavirus j'ai reçu le
message du frère président vladimir
poutine qui a confirmé son soutien
stratégique global dans tous les
domaines des changes
j'ai également parlé avec antonio
gutiérrez secrétaire général de l'onu
qui a exprimé son soutien humanitaire
pour affronter le co by 19 en plus d'une
inflation importante synonyme de pire
crise économique de son histoire le
venezuela se prépare donc à affronter
impossible désastre sanitaire
malgré cette terrible menace les
etats-unis ont décidé de poursuivre
leurs sanctions contre le pays
un choix qui va à l'encontre de l'esprit
humanitaire fondamentale selon un porte
parole de la diplomatie chinoise et dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
la crise du coronavirus en france on
dénombre plus de 3000 décès dont 418 de
plus ces dernières 24 heures dans les
hôpitaux
puis nous parlerons des petites
entreprises qui subissent de plein fouet
la crise alors que le gouvernement a mis
en place un fonds de solidarité bruno le
maire annonce un assouplissement des
règles d'indemnisation en avril à rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
usé de mater la société tous les témoins
de notre époque sont dans la grande
interview comme on a fait de notre pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout opposait se
sont forgées de la destinée commune dans
une perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir toucher les amines le
but ultime c'est pas forcément de gagner
des médailles welsh podium m6 d'arriver
à gérer ses émotions dans un certain
nombre et c'est un univers qui vous
permet justement d'aller encore plus
loin dans cet état d'introspection et de
travail sur le corps et aussi sur les
plus on va être dans l'instant présent
et on va être capable de gérer ce qu'on
en a à faire est concentré sur ce que
l'on fait donc c'est ta confiance et la
capacité à vivre l'instant présent à
être connectés que sur ce qui se passe
sur les sons sur le toucher sur le
ressenti et ça nous pousse dans les
retranchements à changer des choses dans
notre propre vie en dehors de l'année le
chantier naval de chittagong est l'un
des endroits les plus difficiles d'accès
de la république du bangladesh des
navires du monde entier sont envoyés
finir leur vie ici
bienvenue dans la zone de démolition des
navires
elle commence ici donc tout ce que vous
allez voir ici vient des navires
c'est à kong est la deuxième ville la
plus grande du bangladesh la population
officielle est de 10 millions
d'habitants mais officieusement il y en
a beaucoup plus à perdre un emploi ici
signifie qu'il y a des centaines voire
des milliers de personnes prêtes à
prendre votre place je sais que mon
travail est très dangereux et j'ai tout
le temps peur d'être grièvement blessé
alors à chaque fois avant d'aller au
chantier je demande une bénédiction à ma
mère et je prie aussi à la mosquée cette
personne à lunettes va nous conduire
dans le chantier de démolition des
navires
il nous a également prévenu que nous ne
pourrions film et que si nous utilisions
de très petites caméras
[Musique]
il y a une problématique d'augmentation
extrêmement importante de la demande en
eau depuis la révolution verte qui a
conduit à cette autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'inde dans ces zones
climatiques aride ya quasiment plus
d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image d'une femme qui porte un
pont à eau sur la tête est une image que
l'on voit partout
pour les femmes c'est une charge énorme
des petites filles peuvent pas aller à
l'école parce qu'elles doivent aider à
cette tâche par exemple donc ça accentue
des inégalités 85% de l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est un
paradoxe en soi
[Musique]
le général guisan en fait été
effectivement est un condisciple main de
napoléon à brienne donc il est l'été
l'école de brienne en même temps en même
temps que napoléon s'est il est mort
donc une des dernières personnes à
l'avoir vue c'est napoléon donc c'est
très important
ensuite c'est un général qui a fait
toute sa carrière militaire qui est mort
au combat qui est mort en russie
c'est l'un des camarades les plus
proches de napoléon son nom est gravé
deux fois sur l'arc de triomphe à paris
on savait évidemment qu'il avait été
enterré en russie seul son coeur avait
été rapatrié en france
au cimetière du père lachaise
[Musique]
on a trouvé les traces d'un enterrement
je ne sais pas lequel michel michaud
attention on touche à rien
on est peut-être à 80 90 % de chances
que la sépulture du général ghislain
soit là
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour une demi heure
d'information il est 21h heure de paris
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 30 mars 2020 en france plus
de 3000 décès dont 418 de plus ces
dernières 24 heures dans les hôpitaux
avec 44 milles 550 cas de coronavirus
confirmés dans le pays
et puis audition ce mercredi du premier
ministre et du ministre de la santé dans
le cadre de la mission d'information sur
le comique 19 de l'assemblée nationale
elle a pour objet d'interroger sur les
mesures déjà prises ainsi que leurs
applications
[Musique]
le fmi le fonds monétaire international
estime qu'une profonde récession en 2020
est un fait acquis sur le vieux
continent en france alors que les
petites et moyennes entreprises sont
touchées de plein fouet par la crise
sanitaire
le gouvernement a mis en place un fonds
de solidarité auxquelles elles pourront
à nouveau avoir accès en avril selon le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
[Musique]
en france les derniers chiffres viennent
de tomber plus de 3000 décès dus au coït
19 dont 418 ces dernières 24 heures dans
les hôpitaux soit la plus forte
augmentation en nombre sur une journée
depuis le début de l'épidémie à près de
21 mille personnes sont actuellement
hospitalisées dont 5056 en réanimation
34% d'entre elles ont moins de 60 ans
plus de vingt mille tests par jour vont
pouvoir être fait avant la fin de la
semaine a annoncé ce soir jérôme salomon
le directeur général de la santé lors du
point presse quotidien le ministère de
la santé qui compte doubler à dix mille
le nombre de lits en réanimation et ils
sont des milliers de français à ne pas
pouvoir passer de tests de dépistage
malgré l'apparition de symptômes
c'est le cas de tania dans la banlieue
de lyon elle et sa famille vivent en
confinement depuis trois semaines luis
carballo et valentin carpentier
voici la seule vue que tania depuis sa
maison depuis déjà trois semaines un
quartier désert et au loin le groupama
stadium un stade qui pour cette mère de
trois enfants est à l'origine de ces
problèmes
atteinte du coït 19 elle est convaincue
de l'avoir contractée le 26 février à
l'occasion du match opposant l'olympique
lyonnais et la juventus de turin dont le
maintien avec la présence de 3000
supporters italiens avaient fait
polémique et interrompre un mystérieux -
il est entre le match et on est en
vacances
je soutiens ce jour et c'était le 26
février elle parce que c'était mon
anniversaire
non que je suis allé au super match et
si jusque là il était plein l'italien il
pour moi c'était rigolo parce que j'ai
dit c'est ma fille on arrive en italie
le monde à battre l'italien paolo
c'était sans plus sept jours après du
commissaire et christine quarantaine
forcée donc pour toute la famille depuis
trois semaines avant même les mesures de
confinement adopté par le gouvernement
le 17 mars dernier trois membres de la
famille sont tombés malades
tania son mari et sa fille aînée
alexandra tous présentent des symptômes
différents mais jusqu'ici aucun d'entre
eux n'a eu le droit au test de dépistage
du coït 19 pour expliquer ces symptômes
tania du passé
et de dépistage des grippes a et b fait
des prélèvements sanguins et une radio
tous ont présenté des résultats négatifs
si c'est le moment ça a été le parcours
du combattant médecin samoa maison
médicale laboratoire radio à la maison
médicale où je t'ai d'expliquer qu'avec
coronavirus sainte est pourquoi ma part
ils sont parfaits et s est simplement
parce qu'il gérait pas tous les cinémas
attendu dans ces moments là donc j'avais
été soufflé tu avais beaucoup et où
j'étais fatigué il y avait mal à la
gauche ne pouvait pas respirer rien
gérer eux mêmes les sons du lot mais je
n'avais pas la fia donc s'il n'y avait
pas la réelle et je pouvais pas y aller
un protocole incompréhensible pour tania
comme pour des milliers de français qui
n'ont pas le droit non plus de se faire
tester les symptômes ont tous disparu
pour tania et sa famille il ne reste
plus qu'à attendre un retour à la
normale une feinte de confinement que la
famille lyonnaise espère impatiemment
comme des milliards de personnes dans le
monde et pour parler de l'évolution de
cette pandémie en france catherine hill
épidémiologiste et lanceuse d' alerte et
en liaison avec une fois catherine hill
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors concernant al
coronavirus les derniers chiffres sont
tombés plus de 3000 décès en france donc
418 ces dernières 24 heures qu'est-ce
qu'ils traduisent de l'évolution de la
pandémie
c'est assez simple le nombre de cas
double tous les quatre jours et le
nombre de morts double tous les trois
mois
donc on peut annoncer les chiffres tous
les jours mais c'est plus important de
regarder la dynamique globale
on est en plein dans l'épidémie le
confinement n'est pas suffisant les gens
sont pas assez confiné ceux qui
continuent à travailler risque d'être
exposés donc il faut réorganiser le
travail pour limiter le nombre de gens
que chaque travailleur rencontre par
exemple dans les ehpad il faut séparer
les gens qui sont positifs et les gens
qui sont pas malades et que ce soit pas
le même personnel qui s'occupe des uns
et des autres il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire
juste justement catherine vous parliez
des ehpad la prise en compte des décès
dans les ehpad ne semble pas faire
partie des chiffres annoncés ce soir
puisqu'ils ont été annoncées ces morts
dans les hôpitaux
est ce que le compte ne serait pas plus
juste justement c'est en prenant en
compte ses morts dans les ehpad de toute
façon les comptes ne sont pas justes
c'est pas vraiment le problème en
surveillant en regardant en ayant le
même outil de mesure
il ya trois jours et aujourd'hui et il
ya six jours et il ya trois jours et
s'est même tous les jours ça va on voit
c'est la dynamique qui compte c'est le
fait que le nombre de morts avec l'outil
de mesure du moment
double tous les trois jours c'est ça ça
suffit concernés alors vous aviez estimé
le nombre de morts dus coronavirus en
france a au moins 64 milles vous vous
attendez toujours à ceux à ce chiffre
oui parce que en fait on connaît les
morts jusqu'à aujourd'hui on connaît les
cas qu'on a diagnostiqué et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais il ya énormément de cas
à la famille que nous venait de raconter
une histoire qui sont pas comptés dans
les cas donc il ya des quantités
industrielles de cas d'ailleurs du cool
la mortalité le risque de mourir être et
d'assez faible finalement peut-être un
an et demi pour cent et donc il ya plein
de cas qui sont pas comptés dans le
dénombrement donc il a énormément plus
de gens aussi qui sont contaminés est
contagieux qui se promène dans la nature
et donc ça ça va rendre la sortie du
confinement très très difficile il va
falloir se mettre à testé massivement la
population à ce qu'est oui alors
effectivement on va y revenir peut-être
avant toujours à propos de l'évolution
de la courbe à quand le pic selon vous
ce fameux peak tant attendue est ce
qu'on peut avoir une idée précise
2 de la rondelle et il va arriver la
seule donnée qu'on a c'est l'observation
ce qui s'est passé à oupeye à aubel on a
comparé aux halles on a confiné le jour
où il ya eu sans diagnostic
le maire gilles c'est-à-dire
extraordinairement tout dans l'épidémie
et on a confiné drastiquement bien plus
qu'ici parce qu'ici on parle d'envoyer
déjà les ouvriers du bâtiment se
remettre au travail et des choses qui
sont vraiment extraordinairement
déraisonnable donc un bourg ain avec un
compliment très strictes il a fallu
pratiquement quatre semaines pour voir
la courbe épidémique s'infléchir
donc ce que vous nous dites ce soir
c'est il faut plus de confinement pour
vous ah oui mais c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est n'importe qui qui a réfléchi
tous les gens qui se promènent qui
travaillent qui rencontre d'autres gens
parmi ces gens là il y en a forcément
qui sont contaminés et donc ils
contaminent d'autres gens et ça va faire
continue alors on a réduit un peu avec
le confinement actuelle mais vraiment il
faut renforcer ce continent alors il ya
aussi la question de la chloroquine qui
suscite le débat la polémique en france
en europe et ailleurs quel est votre
regard vous sur cette molécule il ce
médicament n'a pas été étudiée
sérieusement dans l'indication du coc
vide
19 on a des il ya une étude chinoise pas
trop mal fait
avec un groupe contrôle 15 patients avec
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine et 15
patients témoins qui ne montre aucune
différence et à part ça on l'a l'étude
le professeur raoul qui sont
extraordinairement de mal faite avec des
défauts d'analysé de conception
monstrueux maintenant il dit qu'il a
traité mille personnes et que je ces
gens là il y en a beaucoup qui vont très
bien je crois qu'il a tendance à
éliminer les gens qui n'ont pas reçus
traitement complètement déjà ça c'est
pas ça enlève tous ceux qui sont mort
vite ça reprend les résultats
sympathique à regarder mais
extraordinairement biaisé
extraordinairement erronée dans tout ça
n'est pas sérieux
et en plus c'est un petit un médicament
qui est cardio toxiques
les gens les plus malades
ont des problèmes cardiaques souvent et
donc c'est vraiment pas une bonne idée
du tout il faut attendre les essais sont
en cours ils vont aller assez vite
encore la réponse bientôt
mais franchement c'est pas très
prometteur alors nyns nous n'y sommes
pas encore a néanmoins à quel moment
pourra t'on avoir la perspective d'un
déconfinement il comment faudra-t-il s'y
prendre ça je ne sais pas très bien il
va falloir tester massivement avoir une
idée de déjà combien le virus est
présent dans la population est ce nous
n'avons aucune idée aucune idée donc on
peut pas parler de confinement donc on a
pas résolu ce problème en tout la rame
en tous les cas pour conclure les tests
de dépistage massif
elle est là pour vous la voie de sortie
aujourd'hui imbrication mais mes parts
par ailleurs on n'a pas besoin
actuellement de tester des gens qui sont
malades et pas trop malades qui sont
chez eux comme la famille donc se faire
raconter l'histoire contador s'était pas
vital de faire un test c'est pas ça
l'urgence quand on va vouloir sortir du
confinement il va bien falloir avoir
mesurer la prévalence de l'infection
dans la population
merci beaucoup catherine hill d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes épidémiologistes et lanceuse
d'alert le confinement est impossible
lorsqu'on vit dans la ruche les sans
domicile fixe font partie des
populations les plus vulnérables face
aux coronavirus de nombreuses
associations sont mobilisées auprès
d'eux pour leur distribuer des repas
exemple à paris c'est dans le quartier
des halles le reportage de piotr
traverse qui est nicolas winckler avec
mathilde romagnan des repas gratuits
distribués aux plus démunis à l'église
saint-eustache dans le quartier des
halles à paris les distributions ont
repris cette semaine pour la première
fois le diocèse et la mérite paris mène
une action commune pour venir en aide
aux sans abri
la ville finance les repas le diocèse
les distribuer le centre de paris et le
plus le plus gros c'est à dire c'est 250
personnes par jour quoi en gros qui ont
besoin
encore une fois soit des gens dans la
rue c'est la majorité parce qu'ici il ya
les des souterrains il ya des tas de
souterrains donc il ya une population
souterraine dans ce quartier est plus
des gens qui sont seuls chez eux tout
simplement et et qui n'ont pas de
revenus donc qui viennent aussi chercher
l'or ont évidemment et on vous fait
aucune différence
ceux qui viennent prendre un sac près
d'un sac et puis voilà le confinement
ajoutent d'autres problèmes aux sans
domicile fixe les sdf difficile de faire
la manche quand il n'y a plus personne
dans la rue impossible de simplement
prendre un café au chaud puisque tous
les bistrots sont fermés c'est dur très
dur très dur porto rigueur oui des
difficultés ok un carton bon on fait la
manche ont fait la marge pour un peu
d'argent un des cigarettes cigarettes
mais le zéro et rouille et un peu tout
ya mis un petit gars n ya plus
d'étrangers qui viennent encore en un
seul en jugeant paris et voilà enfin
celle du tout le ministère du logement a
annoncé l'ouverture de 5000 places
d'hébergement supplémentaires dans des
hôtels pour accueillir les sdf
une mesure qui ne semble pas encore
suffisantes l'état a livré sa 1000
chambres d'hôtel pour moi je vois
toujours tout le monde dans la rue à
dormir dans la rue tard et alors c'est
passé qui conte mais dans les chambres
moi je vois personne de ma connaissance
je vois personne
autre problème le respect de la
distanciation sociales et des
gestes-barrières impossible à appliquer
de nombreux wc publics sont ainsi fermé
en vivant dans la rue les sans abri
reste donc particulièrement exposés au
virus
oui dans paris on là ils ont tout de
suite dit bon les gens de la rue on les
laisse dans la rue ils ont toutes façons
nulle part où aller
donc qu'ils restent dans les coins on
connaît les coins et on
on surveille fins et c'est ce que j'ai
entendu dire on surveille que ça se
passe bien quoi le problème c'est que
c'est des coins contaminants évidemment
enfin ils dorment dans les souterrains
ici dit dom ils font pas un mètre de
distance entre 40 sites de confinement
sont actuellement prêts à accueillir les
sans domiciles touché par le coronavirus
selon le ministère du logement
il y aurait pour l'instant un peu plus
de 600 cas de sdf contaminées dans toute
la france selon le ministère et puis en
première ligne face à la crise
économique engendrée par le coronavirus
les petites et moyennes entreprises
restaurants cafés cinémas ou commerces
de proximité ils sont nombreux à
craindre la faillite
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'économie
annonce un renforcement des aides aux
tpe et aux pme
à l'aide de 1500 euros à ces entreprises
est ainsi élargi alors de quoi s'agit-il
exactement
explications en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour parler de la situation de ces
tpe et de ces pme nous sommes avec
philippe herlin économiste philippe
herlin bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors 50 % de
baisse du chiffre d'affaires au lieu de
70 % de baisse jusqu'à maintenant pour
toucher une aide de l'état
comment est-ce que vous accueillez ses
déclarations du ministre de l'économie
on ne le poussera peu sévère parce que
ça contre 110 % ça dépend complètement
d'effecteur quoi et et on voit que le la
chute du chiffre d'affaires et abidal
bon il ya aujourd'hui des sites de la
fcpe qui par eux qui confirme fait de
lille c'est d'ailleurs les quelques
jours qui dit que à mois d'arrêt ça fait
3 % de pib en moins sur l'année et il ya
un certain nombre de secteurs qui sont
quasiment à l'arrêt tout ce qui est
tourisme transport tout ce qui est
service des taxes et terrasse est à
l'arrêt donc faire une distinction entre
50 70 % de toute façon ce sont deux
chiffres de chutes de chiffre d'affaires
qui condamne la plupart des entreprises
surtout qu'il faut bien comprendre que
beaucoup d'entreprises c'est déjà en
difficulté avant il ya eu il ya eu les
gilet jaune pendant longtemps il ya eu
il ya eu les grèves de redescendre et
janvier donc pour que nos entreprises
sont déjà affaiblies donc une chute de
chiffre d'affaires de 50 70 fin mai même
30% se suffit à les mettre par terre
donc je trouve c'est un revirement kéké
paquet pas intelligent quoi est-ce que
cet assouplissement est ce qui n'arrive
pas un peu trop tard quand on sait que
l'organisation professionnelle qui
représente les commerçants réclament que
cette mesure s'applique aussi aux mois
de mars et pas seulement au mois d'avril
oui parce que mars a été à un mois qui a
vu le début du confinement donc il ya eu
au moins une bonne semaine de perdue il
ya que les commerces alimentaires qui
s'en sont tirés évidemment tous les
autres ont commencé à fermer donc
évident qu'il faut il faut intégrer une
mois de mars mais on voit dans les
difficultés là que se posent les tasses
et que l'état français n'a pas
suffisamment d'argent il se rend compte
que ça va coûter trop cher et si ça le
problème c'est que la france elle même
face à l'état français le budget l'état
est arrivé face à cette crise déjà d'un
situation extrêmement dégradée
la france avait déficit public le plus
important des pieds européen à voir la
crise la france n'a pas profité des
moments où il y avait un peu de
croissance ou dix ans il n'y avait pas
de crise pour remettre ses contres à l'
équilibre c est aujourd'hui alors qu'il
faut faire face à cet événement a prévu
et est très brutal et d'un ya plus
d'argent et là on voit la différence
radicale par rapport à l'allemagne
l'allemagne à elle avait à des excédents
budgétaires pendant plusieurs années
mais elle a fait l'effort de rétablir
ses comptes et même de mettre de
l'argent de côté et maintenant
l'allemagne à un plan des dons aux
tristes qui se chiffrent à 1100
milliards d'euros la france sait même
pas la moitié est donc
le premier lot maire se rend compte
qu'il va devoir limiter les aides et ça
pose un problème parce que ça va mettre
beaucoup d'entreprises sur le tapis quoi
c'est à dire qu'un fonds de solidarité a
annoncé 1 1 milliard d'euros pour le
seul mois de mars
l'état n'a pas les moyens de ses
ambitions aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous
nous dites oui tout à fait babillard de
sama ridicule face avant que quand
comptant par à l'allemagne qui a pays
qui est un peu plus grande où il est
mais il faut re milliards et en plus eux
ils sont pas dans un confinement total
parce que eux ils ont ils ont plus de
moyens en terme de santé dont ils sont
la capacité à faire des tests beaucoup
plus nombreux que les nôtres et donc à
ne pas être obligé de faire un
compliment total comme nous le faisons
donc l'allemagne est en fait moins
touché que nous et elle met beaucoup
plus d'argent sur la table donc
l'allemagne risque de s'en tirer
beaucoup mieux et les pays qui sont en
situation de déficit comme la france et
l'italie et rex de prendre le risque de
prendre beaucoup de retard par rapport à
quand le corner virus quand la crise
sera terminée et ça c'est vraiment
problématique parce que les touristes
qui font faillite les bars on pourra pas
les ressusciter quoi voilà alors bruno
le maire reconnaît une aide je le cite
un peu courte pour certains commerçants
est en danger est ce que c'est un aveu
d'impuissance ou au contraire un signe
d'encouragement pour la suite
non en fait un aveu d'impuissance qui
était très clair surtout que compte tenu
de la gravité de la crise il faudrait
pas seulement reporter les échéances
fiscales il faudra garder des remises
d'impôts carrément est ça la france
aujourd'hui elle est l'un des biens est
capable c'est tout le problème quoi donc
les dépenses publiques en france n'ont
cessé d'augmenter même quand il y avait
des périodes assez phase de croissance
plus ou moins importante les dépenses
n'ont jamais été maîtrisé en france et
est là le problème c'est que l'état et
se trouve lui aussi exemple parce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que les recettes
fiscales de l'état elle s'effondre aussi
la tva s'effondre les recettes des sens
qui compte de carburant qui que repenti
part importante des recettes de l'état
et elle s'effondre aussi compétent parce
que plus personne ne roule et et donc
l'état lui il avait déjà un déficit
important avant la crise et il voit ses
recettes fiscales s'effondrer
complètement et il se rend compte qu'il
va pas pouvoir faire grand chose pour
l'entreprise alors que 1 et à se faire
justement à ça enfin c'est un événement
enterré comme celui-là qui peut être une
guerre
ou qui peut ou cook et à une pandémie
comme aujourd'hui
et là qu'on compte sur l'état est le
problème c'est que la france ne pourra
pas vraiment aider les entreprises à
passer ce cap il y en a beaucoup qui
vont rafler sur le tapis est en fait
très dommageable parce que là ça veut
dire que la récession va se poursuivre
après la crise du corps d'un virus en un
mot pour conclure quelle conclusion on
peut d'ores et déjà tirer ou faudra-t-il
tirer de cette crise économique en
france liées aux coronavirus à la
conclusion c'est je crois qu'il faut que
l'état fasse comme les particuliers
comme vrai c'est à dire qu'ils mettent
de l'argent de côté voilà d'ailleurs
qu'il équilibre ses comptes et mais
j'irai plus loin que l'état doit avoir
une épargne doit avoir un fond un peu
comme des pays ont des fonds souverains
la norvège par exemple la france ouvre
ainsi et elle peut puiser dedans c'est à
dire elle peut apporter de l'argent à
l'économie sans être obligés d'augmenter
les impôts et sans créer de déficit moi
je considère qu'en état normal
aujourd'hui doit avoir un fond souverain
doit avoir des économies de façon à
pouvoir puiser dedans lors d'une crise
imprévue comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup philippe herlin d'avoir
partagé avec la valise je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste et puis sur les
plus de 700 milles cadeau qu visite
qu'ovide 19 recensés dans le monde
140000 viennent des états unis c'est le
premier foyer mondial de la pandémie
donald trump craint cent mille à 200
mille décès le président américain
prévoit un pic épidémique d'ici deux
semaines grégoire ou c'est l'optimisme
de donald trump se heurte à la réalité
du coronavirus c'est désormais officiel
le président américain ne lèvera pas les
mesures de distanciation social avant
pâques comme il l'avait prévu pour la mi
avril c'est dorénavant le pic épidémique
qui est à l'ordre du jour des magpies
portenard je veux que le peuple
américain sache que vos efforts
désintéressé inspirant et courageux sauf
dénombrable vie fait la différence
la modélisation estime que le pic du
taux de mortalité
devrait être atteint dans les deux
semaines en ans et reagan je le répète
le pic le point culminant du taux de
mortalité n'oubliez pas il est probable
qu'il soit atteint dans deux semaines
hendrix rien ne serait pire que de
déclarer la victoire avant que la
victoire ne soit acquise
ce serait là notre plus grande perte
le milliardaire américain qui a ensuite
exhorté la population à être disciplinés
week end les deux prochaines semaines et
pendant cette période il est très
important que chacun suive
rigoureusement les directives recommandé
par notre grand vice président il y
tient beaucoup
il y croit fermement mieux vous et
j'irai plus vite ce cauchemar prendra
fin fo 1
c'est pourquoi nous allons prolonger nos
lignes directrices jusqu'au 30 avril
pour ralentir la propagation
l'immunologiste anthony fochi conseiller
du locataire de la maison blanche estime
lui que le virus pourrait tuer entre
100000 et 200 mille personnes dans le
pays selon les derniers chiffres
officiels environ 135 mille cas ont été
recensés dont plus de 2300 décès et 2600
personnes guéries pour venir à bout du
coït 19 donald trump oriente sa
stratégie sur les tests rapides
le déploiement des tests rapides va
considérablement accéléré notre capacité
à surveiller suivre contenir et
finalement vaincre le virus nous
vaincrons le virus il nous permettra
également de tester immédiatement les
médecins les infirmières et les autres
travailleurs de la santé et d'agir
rapidement et énergiquement pour arrêter
la propagation du virus
si importante dans les installations
critiques tels que les hôpitaux et les
maisons de soins alors que le président
américain a renoncé à placer l'état de
new york en quarantaine plusieurs
initiatives voient le jour sur place ici
à central park
une ong installe un hôpital de campagne
qui pourraient être opérationnelles en
ce début de semaine et avant de refermer
ce journal place à un tour du monde en
images
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
ans
on
oh
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de cette émission un peu
écourtée en raison du coronavirus et
comme tous les médias nous sommes
contraints de réduire nos programmes
proches un point complet sur l'actualité
demain à 9h prenez soin de vous et très
bonne soirée sur rt france
[Musique]
le
oui